عموما ليست المره الاولى التي يرصد فيها
من تاضن صيني في اجواء الولايات المتحده
وذلك بحسب مسؤولين امريكيين لكن يبدو ان
هذا البالون او المنطاد باقي نائل لفتره
اطول من المعتاد بحسب ما نقلت رويترز
المنطاد عاده ما يحمل كاميرا للمراقبه
والاستطلاع الجويه قد يحتوي ايضا على
معدات كارادار وفقا لصحيفه الجارديان وفي
حاله هذا المنطاد يرجح خبراء انه مزود
بلواقض ترصد الاتصالات العسكريه الامريكيه
واشارات اخرى استخباراتيه اقله لاغراض
معرفه التجاوب الامريكي مع خطر اختراق من
طاب للاجواء ربما يفسر ذلك بقاء المنطاد
فتره اطول مع استغلال تحسس واشنطن خطوره
اسقاطه
السؤال المهم هل تقصدت بكين التجسس على
الولايات المتحده لغرض معين هل تستهدف
بالفعل منطقه او منشاه حساسه بعينها
المنطاد حلق فوق جزر
في الاسكا وعبر كندا قبل ان يظهر فوق
مدينه بيلينكس في مونتانا ومونتانا هي
موطنا لواحد من ثلاثه اماكن فقد في
الولايات المتحده تخزن فيها الصواريخ
النوويه في قاعده الجويه